the eyes of the world on the European
Parliament for its extraordinary debate
of the results of the United Kingdom's
decision to leave the EU somehow in the
oceans of confusion and uncertainty that
followed the vote to try to preserve
even build unity among the remaining 27
come in T along and I'm Egon or Ganon
history and shadowing the environment in
clinic I skipped often border and then
tried on disabilities in focus about
Island the other bill Gothenburg our
operation on your own but we got there
was a standing ovation for the British
EU Commission or Lord Hill for his
decision to resign so glad his guns Asia
about everything for lot Hill by rights
and Xena
that's the fact when our streets what's
a doer rights begun and heart over to
the european council currently presided
by the netherlands and the commission do
UK is and will always be a european
nation jury demand over the club you
fear the period happy democracy blasted
via song
next up leaders from Parliament's eight
political groups it is a victory of the
populist simulation of the nationalists
on both sides of the channel
show us Europe's future is now at a
crossroad only one thing counts
we the fast majority of this house stand
for the idea of a united peaceful and
tolerant Europe and the populist should
notice no pro bono amo civility a rope a
see Prevnar edit co-directed a
presidental a commission arrow arrow pea
he leadeth a union or opa else indigo de
ropa
questo significa que our own a rose
party or political bureau pale from the
leader in parliament of britain's
governing conservatives this we should
now all respect the democratic will the
British people and work together and
move on and both sides a channel we need
to pause and start thinking about our
negotiating strategies what makes it so
hard for me and I think also for the
other groups leader and for everybody
here in this house is the way it's
exceeded the absolute
negative campaign the posters of mr.
farrar show away refugees like the Nazi
propaganda from the left a plea for
respect and help for those UK citizens
who voted to stay it's con kind of
aren't long gaben so long as you put
this of the gear on an ostrich out there
y una specialist not notified Ciutat Bob
tears are pouring registration typically
for immediate went immediately they mine
off the steamer hydrogen tried on the
vaillar
available in Shortland on him not on our
lands to respect he honest boo Multi
multi gaffe keeper qua two men look we
saw this at a moment in European peace a
fast sir mister Farraj architect of
Britain's out campaign then took the
floor the main reason the United Kingdom
voted the way that it did is you have by
stealth by deception without ever
telling the truth to the British or the
rest of the peoples of Europe you have
imposed upon them a political union
Donella me Brittany Kofi Annan sake do
you mean either in European and Aloha
leave a more historical example talk a
canonical Contino the phylogeny of the
Bella cetacean deliver a over here Oman
don't you say to see rocky damu Don
Pablo for something the debate was a
scene set her open for everyone to see
and hear the arguments however heated
the next phase in this saga is behind
closed doors talks at the council